- Do you understand that if
I told you,
if I took this moment
for all hundred-plus of us and
went back 15 years from ago
and said, "Let me show you what
"you're gonna be doing
exactly 15 years from today,"
we would all
be like, "Holy shit."
(light music)
Morning Vayner Nation.
We haven't been doing DailyVee.
We started DailyVee right after
football season so I guess this
is a good time for a public
service announcement which is
please take all my Monday
interactions after Jets losses
with some level of context.
You know, it's funny, I talk so
high level, don't let the little
things but it's amazing what
the passion of escapism means.
For me the Jets is like the one
place in the world that I don't
have perspective that
I'm allowed to escape.
And it takes me away from all
my reality and it's actually
stunningly relaxing even though
I seem quite wound up and pissed
and all you know, but boy,
yesterday was tough.
Congrats on the Bengal fans.
Happy for you guys.
That's a franchise that hasn't
won a Super Bowl
either ever and has
and we haven't won one since
1969 and Jets beat the Bengals
in a huge playoff
game several years ago.
Not that long ago, actually
2009 I went there and fans would
gracious and so I have a lot of
respect plus my friend Nate,
my friend Ian,
good Bengal fans so.
I'm never happy for anybody
but at least I could
be somewhat respectful.
Never happy for
anybody in football.
You know what's so weird?
I'm almost like the bizarro
version myself in football.
I'm like literally
the polar opposite.
Anyway I'm fucking crushed.
(light music)
Thank you.
Salty as fuck this morning.
Huge Jets loss.
Take a coffee when
you get a chance.
Such a pleasure.
- My pleasure, thank you.
- Marriott and Hilton
shoulda created Airbnb.
- Oh for sure.
- You know?
All those taxi medallion people
they should've created Uber.
- Right.
- The person that's getting
disrupted, Borders and
Barnes &amp; Noble's was in a much
better place than Amazon
to become Amazon.
- Sure.
- You know but
they don't want to.
On this episode I'm in a
salty mood 'cause the Jets lost.
You know what
happens with Salty Vee?
Is that I eliminate any
thought of entertainment and
I just give answers.
Here's how that gets against
this, here is the outside
liability of that and how is
VaynerMedia getting reimbursed
for that number or if not
what I am I doing with
Steve duh-duh-duh.
- The P-and-L--
- [Gary] Oh, it's a
monster difference.
- [Man] Crew here.
- [Gary] Good to
see you brother.
How was your summer?
My man.
Quite a jacket.
- Thank you.
- Got it.
Create the ideas then in a
box then go find somebody.
I think another thing to add and
I wonder if you brought this up,
again, back to a similar vibe,
the other thing I think about
that I'm gonna bring to the
table is not only 'cause you can
but because the upside so
amazingly outweighs
the downside.
If you really think about
what they spend their money on,
putting five or 10 or
$15 million against this initiative
these brands is nothing yet
could be so impactful if you
figured it out.
By the way, I do think this
is a zero to hundred game.
Like this is superhard like to
me it's like either you figured
it out and you got all the
credit and it all worked or
it's just something half
pregnant and did nothing.
And the punchline is for them
is, for all of them, is who's
gonna be the first to win.
'Cause all the
value comes from that.
- [Woman] Thanks so much, Gary.
- You're welcome.
Such a pleasure.
But, you know, if there's a 12,
9-year-old me
as a kid I would've
love right now to be
influencing that person, right?
There's a lot of young
entrepreneurs and if you're in a
8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13,
14-year-old entrepreneur my
content I want to be at the
forefront and I want to be in
your purview and
I want you know who I am.
If you are not waking up every
morning and checking the top 150
free apps on the Apple charts,
you're making a huge mistake.
That's where Marco
Polo caught my attention.
That's where
Musical.ly caught my attention.
Snapchat caught my attention.
It's a very simple way for a lot
of you to keep up with
where the opportunities are.
So instead of having you drink
of water to this question
I'm gonna show you
where the water is.
Because then you become media
not just somebody within it.
Just like I did
with Wine Library TV.
I became the media not just a
retailer selling off the media
I think that's
a really good idea.
America doesn't care
about the mistake.
America cares
about the cover-up.
We're not mad at Samsung for
the battery that goes on fire
because all of us who are
even-keeled recognize that
sometimes that happens
when you're innovating.
What we'd hate is a little, you
know, person's house burns down
and Samsung goes that's not us.
We hate the cover-up.
I mean like, really, we are a
forgiving, forgiving nation.
What we don't want is any
company thinking they're gonna
pull one over on us.
It's unbelievable.
We are visceral to the bullshit.
So I don't think there's
any one-size-fits-all.
I would just say the most
authentic in the
fastest way possible.
I think what excites me most,
Jen, is that this last 10 years
for me has been really about
social media, the evolution of
communication on the internet.
What VR and everything that
Elon Musk's always up to and
what Apple's up to,
and Alexa with Amazon AI
and Pokémon GO,
and filters on Snapchat is
wait a minute, this is a
next-generation
technology that's coming and
I don't know everything.
You know the last one was really
good for me because it was about
human communication.
I believe that to be true for
the next generation but I think
what most excites me is if
you're paying attention what's
happened over the last
year, self driving cars,
we're starting to see the
real life version of things that
have been talked about for the
last three or four years and
I think we can all agree that
10 years from today the
world's gonna be
very, very, very different.
Can we just take a step back?
Does anybody understand
what's happening right now?
To do what we're doing right now
which is have three people doing
video interaction
with each other clean.
This is very clean.
To have how many of our
people watching right now
wherever they are, do you
understand that if I told you,
if I took this moment for all
hundred-plus of us and went back
15 years from ago and said,
"Let me show you
what you're gonna be
"doing exactly
15 years from today,"
we would all
be like, "Holy shit."
Forget about where we're going.
How about just being captivated
by the fact that we're living in
this right this second?
(light music)
As you go down this path
this is what happened
to me at some level you just
realize you just kinda keep
saying it and you let the
chips fall where they fall.
This is why winners
win and losers lose.
If you're gonna look for the
no then you'll find the no and
you'll be in the no camp.
Losses and wasted time are
actually wins in the gathering
of context in a world where the
value of knowing
has never been greater.
So let me say one more time
because I know, that was an
interesting kind of like answer
I don't think people realize
that doing the work to learn all
these things is a win in itself
even if it doesn't
create short-term victories.
I equate it to the following:
we're living a digital marathon
and most people aren't willing
to get on the treadmill for a
couple months to
get ready for it.
(hip hop music)